[MUSIC]
DANIEL CLARO: What
we try to do is
try to figure out what's
the best approach.
Taking a flexible
perspective and understanding
that people learn
differently I think
is a really important
part of what
we're trying to do here in
the Digital Learning Lab.
And technology is an
integral part of that
because technology offers
possibilities to suit
different kinds of learning.
These days, students
who arrive at Princeton
will have been using
computers through most
of their academic life already.
These are digital natives.
And the group that the Digital
Learning Lab is part of
is the Educational and
Classroom Technologies Group
within the McGraw Center.
And the Educational
Technologies Group
helps faculty teach
with technology.
I t helps students
learn with technology.
But what we bring to the
table is a commitment
to making what happens
in the classroom more
interesting, more
inspiring, more engaging
for a diverse audience.
REBECCA GRAVES-BAYAZITOGLU:
The Digital Learning Lab
is a teaching lab.
And it's a space where
faculty, who more and more
are asking students to produce
not your traditional term
paper, but a video or a blog,
and have a space where they can
either send their
students or come and work
with their students to do that.
One of the real privileges
of a Princeton education
is not only to have
access to that,
but have the access to the
support and the training.
My colleagues engage
in a real dialogue
with the faculty who are
employing these technologies
to make sure that they're
being used not simply as bells
and whistles, but as a really
integral part of conveying
the information to the students
and helping the students gain
the capacity to use
it in important ways.
DANIEL CLARO: What faculty
who have used the space know
and what faculty
who inquire find out
is that it's not just a space
with a bunch of computers.
But rather it's a space with
a bunch of computers and staff
who are actively engaged
with the projects that
are happening here.
MARTHA SANDWEISS: I'm teaching
a freshman seminar this semester
that is connected to a larger
project I've been running
for the past few
years that explores
the question of
Princeton and slavery.
Each of the students in my
class has the assignment
of finding another Princeton
student, or an alum,
or a faculty member,
or a staff member,
and talking to them about
their own family's engagement
at the institution of slavery.
And as I began
asking around trying
to understand what
resources here at Princeton
would help me help my students,
I learned about the DLL.
And what we'll be doing at
the Digital Learning Lab
is editing these
audio interviews
and then they'll be
learning how to overlay
those audio interviews with
music, with visual images,
with documents.
So that each student
will be producing
about a five-minute
audio-visual piece
that will be mounted on the
Princeton and Slavery website.
ALEXA FISHMAN: I did a lot
of journalism in high school
so I did a lot of
interviews in the past.
And I think this is actually
a much more interesting way
to present information because
hearing the actual subject talk
and the emotion when she
discusses her family, pairing
that with the images,
it just brings
her audio pieces to life.
TANIA BORE: They may
be familiar with it
but they're not familiar
with using things like this
for like a classroom setting.
I think it can bring a lot
of excitement to projects.
Also learn a new skill
that they probably
will end up using at some
point, because technology
has become such an integral
part of our everyday lives.
DANIEL CLARO: One of the things
that we pride ourselves on here
is the peer-to-peer
training that we offer.
We have students here who
have done many, many video
projects who are really good
at using MATLAB, for example.
So if a student
comes in here saying,
I have a project in
MATLAB, I'm having trouble,
I don't know how
to do it, then we
can connect that
student who needs
help to one of our
student staff members
who are a specialist
in that area.
JESSICA COLANGELO: When
you're going after school
and working in the industry,
an architecture student
or if you're a science major,
we have to communicate our work
and Digital Learning Lab is a
great resource for the students
to get a jump start into like
a primer on the software.
JORDAN ANTEBI: I had
never heard of the DLL.
I didn't even know
that this room existed.
Before I came to this class,
I had no experience at all
with filmmaking, with film
editing, with audio editing.
So the staff at the
Digital Learning Lab
have been very, very, very, very
helpful throughout the process.
MARTHA SANDWEISS: By
producing these short videos
for publication on
a website, we're
showing students
that history matters,
that their work can
find an audience,
and it's really exciting.
REBECCA GRAVES-BAYAZITOGLU:
The technology
allows us to think about new
ways of conveying information
but in no way
eclipses the question
of how do we do that well,
how do we reach our students,
and help them
understand the material
and understand the
concepts in such a way
that they're able to apply
them beyond whatever problem
we give them in the classroom.